Speaker 1: Florida Governor Ron DeSantis is
not yet even a real campaign campaign might
already be collapsing.
And I have to tell you, I have very mixed
feelings about it.
On the one hand, I am enjoying the cringe
and the disasters that are plaguing Ron DeSantis
daily because it's just so entertaining and
it really couldn't happen to a worse guy.
On the other hand, I also recognize that Trump's
a disaster, and DeSantis failings are good
for Trump, and it's hard to get behind things
that are good for Trump as well.
But let me tell you what's been going on amid
flooding in Florida as well.
As long gas lines which are currently happening
as a result of the flooding.
Ron DeSantis has been out on a non-campaign
campaign book related events, and yesterday
he was in South Carolina at an event with
his wife, which went so cringe so quick that
it's actually hard to believe.
Let's look at a couple of clips of this.
Ron appearing with Casey DeSantis, and they
tell a very coordinated story.
You know, DeSantis is in this war with Disney
and Disney World down in Florida, and they
tell this story about how, you know, they
had a Disney wedding or something, but it
was all before they fell in love at Disney.
But it was all before Disney went woke.
And it only gets worse from there.
And the coordinated and scripted nature of
this, it's so cringe and he's pulling his
wife into it.
And the mega-donors that were thinking about
backing the Santas are already bailing.
And I'm going to tell you about that in a
moment.
I'm getting ahead of myself.
Let's start with this event.
Listen to this heartwarming story of love
from the governor.
Speaker 2: One day she comes to me and says,
you know.
Speaker 1: She comes to me with tears in her
eyes and she says, sir.
Speaker 2: I'm going to my parents.
And they were interested in potentially doing
the wedding at.
Speaker 3: Walt Disney World.
Speaker 4: Oh.
Speaker 3: I remember when this broke in the
news, I thought it was so scandalous, like
DeSantis got married to Disney.
Like, yeah, it was great back then.
But he had one caveat though, when I because
he was very gracious.
Speaker 1: Casey DeSantis is even using Trump's
mannerisms, interestingly.
Speaker 3: Enough, that you go do what you
want to do.
This is your thing of wonderful And we grew
up coming from Ohio, go into Disney.
We had a lot of fun before they went broke.
Obviously super fun.
But it was one caveat.
He said, you can do it, however.
Speaker 2: No, Mickey, Donald, Duck, anybody
at the wedding ceremony, they actually have
a wedding.
It's really nice and and everything worked
out.
It was traditional fact.
You look at our wedding pictures, you wouldn't
know that it was anything, you know.
Speaker 1: Isn't this just a great story,
guys?
Speaker 2: Anything out of the ordinary.
But, you know, we're doing that and then thinking
about.
So this was I mean, this is almost 15 years
ago.
And then we're no one was thinking like that.
Somehow this would end up being something
we would be involved with, you know, know
going toe to toe with them about about gender,
ideology and kindergarten.
Are you kidding me?
I mean, it's just absurd.
Speaker 1: Kindergarten.
That's interesting.
Speaker 2: But that's just the way life works.
Speaker 3: It's so funny because people would
say, Oh, did you ever see, you know, that
the governor was going to be the governor?
I'm like, you know, when we when I first met
him, he was a cute guy in the Navy, Like I
fell for the white uniform, right?
Like, he's very handsome.
He was like Tom.
Speaker 1: Just like that.
Does she actually say Tom Cruise.
Speaker 3: Arm, right leg was very handsome.
It was like Tom Cruise.
It was.
Speaker 1: I was going to jokingly say, just
like Tom Tom Cruise in Tough Top Gun or whatever.
Few good men this is.
This is not helping.
DeSantis That's the really interesting thing,
this obsession with Disney.
I mean, okay, cringeworthy scripted story.
Fine.
This is really not helping the Santas.
He's in South Carolina telling Disney stories
while Florida is in chaos due to flooding
and gas lines.
And meanwhile, when he is in Florida, he's
just obsessed with Disney World to such a
degree that even some Republicans like Larry
Kudlow are saying this really isn't looking
very good.
He then did like a more formal event in South
Carolina about the Florida blueprint, I guess
trying to portray the idea that South Carolina
and other red states should copy the blueprint
of Florida, which quite frankly, is a very,
very mediocre state.
You all know I love going to Florida.
I go down in Miami, I go to the, you know,
liberal areas.
I met hipster cafes and all this stuff.
But the truth is that if you zoom out and
look at the state in some total, it's a very
mediocre state, not particularly good or bad
when it comes to infrastructure, crime, Education
does look around 25th out of 50 in most categories.
Why would you follow that as a blueprint?
Well, here, he explains, part of the blueprint
is you got to get woke out and transgender
and all this stuff that's driving donors away.
Speaker 2: The people also side with us on
wanting an economy where businesses focus
on their core mission of providing whatever
service or whatever they're doing in the economy
and not getting mired into a woke political
activism.
And you see it time and time again.
Sometimes it's a one off like this ridiculous
thing with with Bud Light by trying to push
the transgenderism.
But what they're doing is.
Speaker 1: Do you guys think that anybody
has been pushed into transgenderism by seeing
or hearing that?
Dylan Mulvaney.
Drank Bud Light and had some kind of a spy
like this.
The very nature of you can push people into
being trans is one of the oldest tropes it
used to be about You can push people into
being gay.
Now it's you can push people into being trans.
Speaker 2: They're corporations, mostly very
wealthy, powerful corporations, and they're
trying to leverage their economic power to
change our country.
Speaker 1: All right.
They're just doing what's profitable.
That's really all that's going on.
And DeSantis, at this point, seeming desperately
obsessed with Disney and with Bud Light.
And just one last clip from this totally deranged
event.
Here is Ron DeSantis saying woke seven times
in 20 seconds.
Speaker 2: So because the woke represents
a war on truth, we have no other recourse
but to wage a war on woke.
We fight the woke in the schools.
We fight the woke in the legislature, we fight
the woke in the corporations.
We will never, ever surrender to the woke
mob.
Florida is where woke goes to die.
Oh.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
There you go.
So this is not a good idea.
DeSantis donors aren't happy with this.
And the polling shows, as I told you two weeks
ago, most people are on the side of Wokeness.
But let's now talk about the trouble that
Desanctis is creating for himself with this
Anti-woke crusade.